das jüdische leben ist integraler
bestandteil der frankfurter geschichte
tatsächlich ist frankfurter geschichte
ohne die geschichte der jüdinnen und
juden in frankfurt undenkbar
[Musik]
mein name ist sabine kösling ich bin
leitende kuratorin hier am jüdischen
museum und ich habe die entwicklung der
dauerausstellung im museum judengasse
und hier im rothschildpark verantwortet
im historischen rothschildallee also
einem historischen wohnhaus der familie
rothschild zeigen wir auf drei etagen
drei thematische zugänge zur jüdischen
geschichte hier in frankfurt die oberste
etage die die besucher innen zuerst
betreten werden heißt geschichte und
gegenwart und wir beginnen mit der
gegenwart
hier stehen wir vor der vitrine impulse
und zeigen einzelne objekte aus dem
gegenwärtigen jüdischen leben hier in
frankfurt zum beispiel den etro clique
petrow ist eine zitrusfrucht die zum
laubhüttenfest im oktober meistens
verwendet wird und kot der jungen einen
beta aus der baum weg synagoge hat uns
nicht nur ein interview gegeben sondern
er hat uns auch thoben seines schnapses
zur verfügung gestellt für die
ausstellung
wir beginnen unsere dauerausstellung mit
der gegenwart das ist ja auch die zeit
in der unsere besucher innen leben deren
schwierigkeiten die konflikte sie kennen
und wir hoffen die jüdische geschichte
und die jüdische gegenwart als
vielfältig als nahbar als menschlich
darzustellen
in der zweiten etage zeigen der
tradition und ritual also in diese
fragestellung
[Musik]
erkennen dass der marschieren und geld
und liebe mit seinen schier ist die
sonne und die ganze welt und das wissen
um ihr werdet seinen chef
[Musik]
wir sind hier in der etage tradition und
ritual hier behandeln wir aspekte des
religiösen jüdischen lebens und wir
haben einen großen raum gewidmet der
zeremonie ahl kunst also jüdischen
kultgegenständen und wir stehen hier vor
der vitrine mit ak füchsen
spendenbüchsen zum teil aus frankfurter
synagogen wie die füchse die gedenke der
armen beschriftet ist oder von
frankfurter silberschmieden oder aber
auch aus israel heutzutage und wiederum
die bandbreite jüdischen lebens zu
zeigen
geschichte und gegenwart und die
wohltätigkeit die cdk spielt immer eine
große rolle
wir haben einen ganz großen raum
eingeräumt die jüdischen zeremonie ahl
kunst denn die jüdische religion praxis
ist vor allem eine praxis es geht um das
tun
es geht um das erfüllen der gebote ganz
handgreiflich mit objekten
daher wollten wir unsere reichhaltige
sammlung von julika von kultgegenständen
auch den besucher innen zeigen wir
möchten die geschichten erzählen wir
möchten nähe entstehen lassen wir
möchten interesse wecken das ist es was
wir mit unserer dauerausstellung
erreichen wollen
in der ersten etage widmen wir uns dem
thema familien und alltag wie in allen
etagen haben wir auch hier eine
installationen zeitgenössischer kunst
hier haben wir ein kunstwerk von mir all
on einen jetzt in hamburg leben der
israelische künstler der
familiengeschichte familientraditionen
die spuren davon in möbeln
die situation von möbeln festhält diese
installation hat er geschaffen extra für
die dauerausstellung des jüdischen
museums
wir möchten hier im museum die
geschichten von menschen erzählen
geschichte in geschichten so nennen wir
es auch wir möchten nähe erzeugen wir
möchten interesse wecken wir möchten in
jüdische geschichte und gegenwart nahbar
machen eine der wichtigsten thesen die
wir uns gesetzt haben für die
entwicklung der neuen dauerausstellung
ist diese das jüdische leben ist
integraler bestandteil der frankfurter
geschichte tatsächlich ist frankfurter
geschichte ohne die geschichte der
jüdinnen und juden in frankfurt
undenkbar und das ist nicht nur für das
20 92 jahrhundert der fall sondern auch
schon in judengasse zeiten es ist uns
ganz wichtig zu zeigen hier lebten
menschen sie hatten eine spezifische
frankfurter kultur ausgebildet sie
bereicherten das leben der stadt und sie
waren selbstverständlich hier zu hause
[Musik]